you
giving someone their style or bumping up
their sense of style to be a better
version of what it is is part of the fun
of what I do and I actually approached
al sharpton they didn't come to me I
approached his people because I felt
that I felt that his image wasn't
engendering the kind of trust that he
should have for what he wanted to do in
his life and I actually approached him
at a party and criticized his what he
was doing and his people got back to me
and said well what would you change and
what would you do and I said well I'll
meet with them I don't photograph anyone
if I can't meet with them first because
if I don't do that then they're just
going to the dentist and they're filled
with fear they don't know who I am
everyone hates their picture being taken
and they're nervous and they're bringing
all of that when I meet with them they
realize it's a collaboration and they
look forward to coming back in the same
way that sarabande tricked herself it's
that similar thing that said I met with
Al Sharpton ahead of time because if he
wasn't going to let me change him I that
was the point I wanted to I wanted to
just change his image tweaked his image
so that it engendered the kind of trust
that he is after in his political life
and I just told them the hair the hair
the hair is not right I see I see you're
working on it I see it's getting flatter
I see it's getting smaller but I want to
take it further can I do that and the
people that were sitting around him were
dying they couldn't believe I was
talking him about his hair but that was
it for me so I said I know you're going
to barber before you're coming have her
get as flat as you can really
come flat and also I wanted to wanted to
give him a different look more of a
banker look suspender look I think
someone in the press commented on his
makeover as if it came out of nowhere
that was my makeover thank you very much
so he came to the studio and you know we
dressed him in his suits but again
tweaked it you know Marva kind of banker
look for the Reverend and the hair the
hair was still wrong so I said with your
permission and you know I have this what
I call glue in my hair and it's not a
black hair product so with his
permission I kind of glued his hair down
and that is the wonderful hair that you
now see oh god I feel like a plastic
surgeon that's revealed someone I'm
usually more discreet about my makeovers
but I think I'll will be okay with it he
picking the music for him was really
challenging because I told him that he
would love the music and it was kind of
he I don't think he believed me and that
was he said you weren't kidding about
the music he said I love the music thank
you and you learn you learn you learn
everything about someone when they're in
front of your camera or I learn
front of my camera and you see our
people leading with their ego are they
leading with their compassion are they
leading with their sexuality are they
leading with their intelligence and then
it gets all broken down and who they are
fuses together and again music helps
that process and I'm really fond of Al
Sharpton because of what I learned about
him when he was in front of my camera
not because of what he says to the press
and I put on among other things on his
soundtrack
as the original sam cooke version of
change is going to come and i was very
very moved by it and there's no need to
explain to anybody why but that is all
about the genesis of who al sharpton is
so again that's what picking that music
is about it's it's hitting someone in
their own deep consciousness of how they
came up and how they were formed as
professionals and humans and even
children